JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Are
we ready to go.
All right.
Good afternoon, ladies
and gentlemen.
Thank you very much for
coming to our session.
I know we have a lot
of interesting
talks to discover today.
First, I would like to
start with a warning.
We will have some good demos,
but they are nowhere near the
keynote demo.
So I think they set us up
for failure today, but
we'll try our best.
So let me first introduce
the speaker.
Since we have quite a few
speakers today, I really want
to give you an overview of
what's going on in the mobile
space and YouTube.
So we will have Andre
Doronichev, who is the product
manager for YouTube Mobile.
He's the guy behind our
wonderful YouTube Mobile app.
He will talk a little bit about
the past and the future
of YouTube Mobile.
We will have guest
speakers from
Flipboard, Arthur and Jason.
And they have recently
launched YouTube API
integration, so this
is very fresh.
You will be able to learn
about their experience.
Hopefully, they will not say
anything bad about our
performance.
But we'll see.
Then we have Kiran Bellubbi
from 955 Dreams.
They build beautiful mobile
consumption experiences.
He will give us a
demo of his app.
And Krishna Menon
from WeVideo.
They focus on creation.
So we'll talk a little bit about
their architecture and
what they're doing
with their app.
Together with me, I also have my
buddy Shannon "JJ" Behrens.
He will lead a panel
discussion towards
the end of this talk.
So let's get into it.
We'll talk about what's in it
for YouTube and for you
developers when it comes
to mobile video.
And then we'll talk about
specific three areas that we
are focusing on.
The traditional strengths of
YouTube, which is creation and
platform for content creation.
We'll talk about curation, which
is something new that we
have been working on, and we
have a wonderful developer
ecosystem around it as well, a
lot of innovative companies
trying to surface content.
And then we'll talk about
beautiful consumption
experience.
And again, for all three of
them, we will talk about what
we do to enable it from API
standpoint and then give you
an example, real life
applications.
At the end, we'll have a panel
discussion, where JJ has some
tough questions to our
participants, and then you are
welcome to join us and ask
your questions as well.
So first, I would like to
introduce Andre, product
manager of YouTube Mobile.
And then, he will talk a little
bit about the past and
the present and the future
of YouTube Mobile.
Thank you, Andre.
ANDRE DORONIHEV:
Thanks, Jarek.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Here you go.
ANDRE DORONIHEV: Hey, guys.
I wish I could land--
like sky dive down
here on stage.
Unfortunately, I didn't today.
I lead product management for
YouTube on Mobile across our
devices and mobile website.
And I want to talk a little bit
about opportunities that
we see in mobile videos.
Now when we launched YouTube
Mobile back in 2006, it was,
as many good products, it was a
toy, a toy for engineers, a
baby product.
Well, guess what.
It has grown up a
lot since then.
Today, we're streaming 600
million playbacks per day on
mobile devices.
Numbers are huge.
Today, hundreds of millions of
phones and tablets can access
full YouTube experience.
And what we really see
is how the user
perception is changing.
So for many users today,
mobile is becoming the
dominant way of accessing
YouTube.
Another trend that we see is
that a lot of users see Mobile
YouTube as a core feature
of their device.
They just expect it to be there,
like those guys, those
are my kids by the way.
These guys, they just don't have
a concept of hey, this
video is not on the device.
For them any touch screen phone
or tablet they can grab
is sort of a magical portal
that allows us to play any
video they have in
mind instantly.
Now, you may say these guys are
biased, and they may be.
But look at our stats.
As I said, 600 million playbacks
per day, but what is
most fascinating is the pace
at which it is growing.
3x year on year, just
in the past year.
Three hours of mobile video
uploaded every single minute.
So far, our goal with mobile
was just to make it work.
We wanted to deliver great
consistent YouTube experience
across all sorts of
mobile platforms.
And the way we achieved that
was the decision we made a
couple of years ago to focus on
Android application as our
core experience, as the place
where we showcased new
features and try out new stuff,
and then scale it
across platforms via HTML5.
That worked really well, and
today you can access YouTube
from your Blackberry OS device
or Windows Phone or iOS
Android, pretty much any modern
smartphone or tablet.
Now, what's next?
You know the world is changing,
and YouTube is
definitely not a website
anymore.
YouTube is this ecosystem of
different devices accessing
the cloud of video.
And it's becoming more and
more channel centric.
So as you have seen already
with the site redesign on
desktop, we are seeing ourselves
as the platform for
the world of hundreds of
millions of channels.
So what we want to achieve with
mobile going forward is
to turn it into daily ritual,
this application that gives
you access to all your
subscriptions
wherever you are instantly.
So let's say you have 10 minutes
to spare on the bus,
you could just grab your phone,
open your field of
subscription updates, and
instantly watch whatever you
want to watch.
Now, it will take us some
work to get there.
We're quite not there yet.
And here's our strategy, how
we want to get there.
First of all, we need to
improve consumption
experience a lot.
We acknowledge that.
Second of all, monetization
is very important to bring
content to mobile.
We need to make sure that
content creators have
incentive to shift the usage
from desktop to mobile.
Otherwise, they wouldn't just
enable videos for mobile
consumption.
And finally, well, you know how
they say today you cannot
spell capitalism without API
in it, so opening up the
ecosystem is very important.
Now, let me talk about
detail consumption.
I'm not sure if you noticed yet
today, we launched the new
YouTube application for Android,
which is bigger than
just another update, because
it's really showcasing our
vision of future consumption
in the future.
First feature that we launched
is the new UI
focused around channels.
We call it the guide.
When you launch the app, you
instantly get access to all
updates from your channels.
And if you have a specific
channel in mind, like you want
to check out the latest
[INAUDIBLE]
for example, you can very easily
swipe the UI to the
right and pick a particular
channel you care about.
OK, you have all this great
video surfaced for you, but
you know how it happens.
You're on the bus.
You have all this
great content.
You know there's something
really cool there.
You try to watch it.
The connection is very slow.
And it's just a pain.
Instead of watching the video,
you're watching the spinner.
And this is unfortunately true
despite all the recent
improvements on mobile networks,
because it really
depends on many factors.
Like right now, in [INAUDIBLE]
there are so many mobile
devices, the network is just
overloaded.
So the second feature we're
introducing today with this
new application we call Wi-Fi
preloading, and it's quite
revolutionary in its way.
What happens is any time your
phone is on Wi-Fi and charger
we will predownload video
content into it and store it
securely on the device.
So that next morning, for
example, you were on charger
and Wi-Fi overnight.
You wake up in the morning.
You get on the shuttle,
commuting to the office, and
you have flaky connection.
You go through tunnels,
and so forth.
But the video's already there,
so you enjoy flawless HD
quality playback in your phone,
and this is really a
great way to improve your
experience on the go.
But now, we also acknowledge
that mobile devices are not
only used on the go.
Truth is, the gesture UI is so
convenient, the touch UI is so
convenient, that many times
you find yourself like
chilling out on the sofa, and
instead of standing up and
turning on your laptop, you'll
grab your phone and explore
YouTube on it.
Now, touch screen is very good
for exploring and engaging
with videos, but video itself
was created to be watched on a
big screen TV.
So the third feature we'll
launch in this
new UI is Play On.
This allows you to connect, to
pair your phone with the TV in
the room or a smart TV in your
room, or like a TiVo box, or a
Nexus Q that was presented
today.
And this way, you can take
best of both worlds.
You're using the UI on the phone
to navigate the side and
pick the video to watch.
And you're using the big
screen TV to play it.
Now the best thing is that
unlike mirroring technologies,
here everything's happening
through the cloud.
So while your TV is playing the
video, you can continue
exploring YouTube
with your phone.
Or you can just leave the
YouTube app and keep it
playing there.
Now to recap, the way we see
consumption in the future--
three things, it's
channel centric.
It's optimized for streaming
on the go, and it makes
devices in the living room work
together in a way that
makes sense.
Now switching the gears, the
second pillar of our strategy,
as I said, is monetization.
And it is important, because
giving great monetization
options to our content creators,
we're unlocking
content on YouTube on mobile.
And this is a very common
problem with many devices
today when you cannot play some
of the videos because
content creators just didn't
feel like enabling them.
We want to make sure that they
have incentive and they have
great options to enable their
content for devices.
Now, for advertisers mobile ads
on YouTube are actually
quite cool, because unlike many
other properties that
struggle with mobile
monetization, in the case of
YouTube the video ad format is
very well understood, and it
brings a lot of value
to advertisers.
So they're willing to
pay more for it.
Finally, by introducing
skippable formats, we're
giving users the choice to
only watch relevant ad
content, which is also
quite great.
And finally, as I said,
third pillar of our
strategy is you guys.
We've seen a lot of success with
mobile video recently,
and we really want to
share it with you.
Well, of course, we don't want
you to use the API to build
clones of YouTube application,
or do things that are
prohibited by our policy, like
downloading content.
But we see it as an opportunity
to explore new use
cases around embedding videos
into existing products or
building video centric
applications, like apps for
content creation, curation,
or different ways
of discovering videos.
So to sum up, mobile video had
seen a lot of success, and
it's growing really
fast right now.
But the ecosystem is
in the very early
stage, its very beginning.
There is a lot of opportunity
with mobile video, and we
really hope that you guys will
take it to new heights.
Thank you.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thanks.
Thanks, Andre.
All right.
So now, first of all, quick
question for you guys.
Who in the room has
used YouTube APIs?
Oh wow.
Great.
So you don't really need this.
For those of you that haven't,
a quick refresher.
We have two sets of APIs, data
APIs and player APIs.
Data APIs allow you to integrate
with our back end,
so pretty much everything you
can do on YouTube.com you can
do programmatically in
your application.
Player APIs allow
you to customize
the playback behavior.
And going back to our topic of
this talk, we will transition
to a specific APIs relevant to
the three menus cases that we
would like to promote.
Before we get there though,
does anybody
know what this is?
Exactly.
So when I see this painting, it
puts creation in my mind.
So we'll talk about creation.
What APIs are relevant to
content creation on mobile.
Well, first of all, you need
authorization in your
application so the
user can upload
video into their account.
And in the old times, people
used client login, this is now
deprecated, and we are all
using OAuth 2, right?
Quiet.
Yeah, unfortunately, that
is not the case.
We're trying to make it easier,
however, in two ways.
One is Android is actually
introducing a new way of
obtaining OAuth 2 token,
GoogleAuthUtil, and there's a
code sample of how we use
it right here below.
As you can see, it's actually
quite simple.
You invoke GoogleAuthUtil
authenticate method.
You provide the user name and
the scope for the token.
You can get a bunch
of exceptions.
For example, if the user hasn't
authorized yet, you get
user recoverable
auth exception.
If the system is overloaded,
you get a transit exception
telling you to retry later.
And then, if things are really
bad, you will get a failure
exception, and that means
don't bother.
You can just give
up right now.
So this is Android.
And for iOS, we have OAuth2
touch controller.
I don't know if you guys have
seen this, but this is open
source code that wraps
the web view.
It makes it very easy to
incorporate all of the flow
into your application.
Another thing that is
important for upload
application is resumable
uploads.
So if you have not used
them in your mobile
apps, check it out.
Really the fundamental part
about it is it uses the
content rage mechanism from
HTTP, and here's a code
snippet of how you can use that
in your application if
you're not using a
client library.
Really the gist of that is you
can query the system to figure
out how many bytes have
been uploaded if
the connection drops.
So this gives you more than a
day to complete an upload.
So somebody creates
a big video.
You can keep trying in the
background, keep pushing some
bytes, curating to see how much
content has been uploaded
and received by us.
And then try again until the
completion, so it makes,
actually, the upload experience
a lot less
frustrating for the user.
And then, finally, metadata
is very important.
We drive video discovery through
metadata related video
content and so forth.
So couple of pieces that
are important.
The developer key, so you can
monitor the performance of
your application.
We actually grant more quota for
applications that identify
themselves with a
developer key.
That's actually required
for uploads.
Some people don't know about
this little trick here.
You can actually add additional
tax to your upload
that are scoped within
the developer key.
So they are not searchable
on YouTube.com.
They are not visible in the user
metadata, but they are
visible in your application.
So then, for example, you can
encode additional information
about the upload that is
meaningful to your
application.
It may not be meaningful
to YouTube.
It's totally opaque to us.
And location information, APIs
allows you to submit the
markup that identifies the
location of the upload.
Obviously, you need the user's
permission, but that is very
handy, because then you can
query for videos, for example,
within specific radius
and so forth.
So here's one example of how
I typically do this.
Without a client library, you
can just create a template,
populate it with the metadata,
and then you will get back,
you will actually post a
document that kind of looks
like this one with all the major
pieces of the metadata.
Here's my developer tag that
I was talking about and my
geolocation information.
So to put it in context.
I put a quick app together that
allows you to basically
capture video.
Let's launch it.
So I'm actually asking
for the account.
I want to use my account.
And then what this app does is
actually, it records video
from the camera, but it does
it frame by frame.
And it applies a nice little
effect to the video frames as
they are received.
So I am recording our panelists,
and then I can then
add the metadata.
So I'm using the tags that
we were talking about.
And then submit.
Agree to terms of service, and
now I'm using resumable upload
to upload the video
to YouTube.
OK.
So this is my little demo.
We'll come back it to
it a little later.
But I'm not a pro, so I'd like
to now transition to pros that
actually build content creation
application and
introduce Krishna
from WeVideo.
Over to you, Krishna.
KRISHNA MENON: Hi, everybody.
My name is Krishna Menon.
I'm the CTO for WeVideo.
And today, I wanted to talking
about our cloud based video
editor, which we've obviously
integrated with YouTube.
But before I get started, I
wanted to show you a short
video clip.
And hopefully, the idea here is
to give you an idea of what
the platform is capable of
doing in terms of the
capabilities for
video editing.
Now, just to set
it in context.
This video was created as part
of a marketing campaign for
the movie Avengers.
And for lack of a better
name, it's a process.
I'll call it crowd sourcing
of movie trailers.
So they put a bunch of short
video clips from the movie up
on our platform, and then
invited users to come in and
use our editor to create
a trailer.
So this was created completely
on our platform by somebody
who's not a professional
editor.
SAMUEL L. JACKSON: War
has started, and we
are hopelessly outgunned.
MALE SPEAKER: We're
not a team.
We're a time bomb.
KRISHNA MENON: This is very well
done, and hopefully you
noticed that the kinds of
effects that were done and
also how the audio and video
effects are synchronized.
And all of that was done
on WeVideo by really an
nonprofessional editor.
So, now a little bit
about what the
architecture of WeVideo.
So it's completely cloud based
if you look up on the top.
It's in the cloud.
The content is delivered
using a CDN.
The storage could be
either our storage.
We also integrate with
Google Drive.
So the content itself could be
sitting on another cloud
storage system.
In terms of applications, we
have applications both for the
consumer and the prosumer, and
we also like to cover all the
different devices.
We've got applications
for smartphones,
tablets, and the desktop.
And what I'm going to do is
quickly show you some of the
user experiences on the
smartphone and the tablet, so
you can see what are the kinds
of things we do on those
applications.
And so first thing I want to do
is just bring up our camera
application.
So this is intended for
the smartphone.
The idea here is that for us
this is an acquisition device,
but it also gives you the
ability to trim content.
So it also allows you
to apply effects and
also share it to YouTube.
So if you look at the projects
here, and if I pick one of the
projects, and I want to add some
content, what it allows
you to do is upload content from
a gallery, or record a
video, or take a picture.
I'm not going to record a video
here, but I do have
something in the gallery.
I did go ahead and record Jarek
when he was talking.
So if I just load that
up, and obviously, I
can play it out here.
And then what I can do is I kind
of trim it if I wanted to
cut out parts of it.
So for us, everything is in real
time, so any trimming or
applying effects, we want to
avoid the rendering process.
Everything needs to be done in
real time, so we'll try to
preview it.
And the key to that is you use
proxy files for content, so we
use a lower bit rate file that
gives you the same kind of
user experience.
Once I'm done with my
trimming, I can
do a style and share.
Since this is intended for a
smartphone, we try to optimize
it for the real estate.
So we have these things called
themes, and themes are
automated effects, which apply
both video effects and also
audio to it.
So if I wanted to go ahead and,
say, apply a memory's
[? theme ?] to that
and play it.
And so if I didn't like that,
and I said I want to change it
to passion again, it's
all real time, and
I can look at it.
And so once I've done that, the
last step is I'll go in
and I'll share it to YouTube
and that's kind of the
smartphone process.
Now all of this gets stored in
a server, so I wanted to
continue editing.
I could go back and work on
my tablet version, which
obviously takes advantage of
the larger real estate.
So if I go to the tablet
version, you'll see that it's
actually a full blown editor.
It's got a timeline with a lot
more effects, titles, audio
recording, and things
like that.
So again, I've got that
project here.
I'll open that up.
And I just started creating
a new movie.
Now, we have this concept
of wizards.
Again, we're trying to
attract the product.
We're trying to go for
the breadth of users.
If you don't want to do the
editing, we also have a wizard
that allows you to quickly
create a movie.
I'll go in, and I'll
pick some videos.
So this is Jarek talking
right here.
But I'm just I'm just going
to go ahead and
use something else.
So I'll pick a couple clips.
Drag it in.
I'll pick another one.
And then what I can also do is--
if I just to play that,
obviously now I put two
clips together.
And if I wanted to go ahead and
put some effects on that,
we've got a big selection of
effects in the application.
And I'll just go ahead,
and we've
got animations, patterns.
I'll do a 3D horizontal effect
at the transition there.
And then I'll just move it so
we don't have to watch the
whole thing.
So as it goes to transition,
you'll see a little effect.
So all of this has been
happening in real
time as it goes on.
And then I can add some titles
to it, or I can add
some audio to it.
So the idea is that, again, we
want to do as much of this in
real time as possible.
And once I'm done editing, I
just publish it to YouTube,
and that process happens
in the background as we
go along with it.
So hopefully, that gives you an
idea of what the product is
capable of doing.
Now, let me talk a little
bit about--
OK, so core technology.
So obviously I talked a
little bit about this.
We support multiple devices
across multiple apps.
Quick thing about it, if you
look at the fourth bullet
there, a proxy.
So that's how we do a
lot of the editing.
We take the high risk file,
create a lower bit rate proxy.
That's how we get the efficiency
and performance
during the editing process.
Again, the idea is you want to
be able to make quick changes
and preview it.
And since this is all based in
the cloud, the whole process
of publishing to YouTube is all
done through a scalable
form that we are encoding from
that we have up in our cloud
infrastructure.
Just kind of looking at the
end to end workflow, so we
integrate both with Google
Drive and YouTube.
So Google Drive is where
all the content sits.
So what we have is that we have
a process that watches
the Google Drive folders to see
any new content comes in.
When that comes in,
we pick it up.
Create the proxy, and then
that's available for editing.
And then you have the option of
putting the published edits
on YouTube, or you can
also store it back
to your Google Drive.
Lastly, talking a little bit
about the integration points.
Obviously, authentication
happens
through open ID and OAuth.
The publishing process, it's
basically, when the user
decides to publish it, we go
through the timeline, create a
single file about it, and then
use GData YouTube API to
publish it to YouTube.
And then the drive integration,
as I mentioned,
happens through synchronizing
our CMS with the drive folder
so we can pick up the new media
files, create the proxy,
and do the editing.
And all of that is
done through the
drive API and the .API.
Thank you.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thanks.
Thanks, Krishna.
I thought you were going to
leave that topic for me.
All right.
So a lot of interesting thing
happens on the back end with
that application.
So now let's talk about
something else.
Again, another picture for
you to guess what it is.
Any thoughts come through to
your mind when you see this?
[INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, so what I see is a
beautiful content in beautiful
settings, which is what content
curation is all about.
So let's chat a little bit about
the APIs that we have
that enable that.
And then give you an example of
a great app that uses them.
So if you use the Google data
APIs you see that we actually
have a set of content
discovery APIs.
For example, you can
search for videos.
You can search for channels.
You can find out what
videos are related.
This is very simple.
You can invoke an
HTTP request.
It gives you a set of entries
that corresponds to videos
that match your search
criteria.
In this case, I was actually
asking for all
minecraft-related videos.
We have some APIs that are
really relevant for creation.
For example, we have an API,
which allows you to figure out
what's on YouTube right now.
And if you have been using the
standard feeds in your app,
you will notice there is an on
the web feed, so you can
actually query to figure
out, tell me what's
trending right now.
Maybe my user will want
to see that and share.
So I have a simple query
expression here.
What I'm asking for two top
entries from the trans feed,
and I'm actually only interested
in the entry name
and the title.
So let me just click on that.
And this is always
a nice surprise.
So here are the two top trending
videos right now.
Kite surfer Reddington Beach.
I wonder if this is better
than our keynote demo.
And then we have some more
APIs coming in this area.
So if you're interested in
this type of curation,
discovery APIs, get in touch
with us, because we are always
looking for trusted testers.
Now, if you have access to
YouTube's account for a
specific users, in other words,
if they have actually
authorized you through OAuth,
you can learn more.
So for example, you can figure
out what videos the user has
saved in order to watch later.
And if you have, again, been
granted the OAuth permission
maybe you can use that to
drive their discovery
experience.
So to do that you can write some
code to do this, or you
can use our handy little
OAuth tool.
Let me see.
This one.
So what I can do is I can
request the OAuth token,
authorize this application
to access my account.
Find, get the access token.
I got the access and the refresh
token, which is nice.
And now I can issue an
authenticated request, so I
have a request, say, looking for
all the videos that I have
saved into my watch
later feed.
So if I just invoke this
operation here, I'll get a
bunch of videos that
have been saved.
If I use the syntax partial
responses with this field's
param, so we can do that, what
I'll actually get is only the
elements that I have explicitly
requested.
So you see this is a lot easier
to parse, and there is
a perfect video that
I wanted to watch.
Didn't have time, because I
was prepping for I/O. I'll
watch it tonight if everything
goes well, and it's saved into
my watch later feed.
So again, this is the type of
stuff you can do if you have
authenticated access to
the YouTube account.
Now, if you Flipboard, you
can also build beautiful
applications that use
these types of APIs.
So I would like to introduce
Arthur, the CTO of Flipboard,
and Jason, who worked on YouTube
integration, to share
their experience.
ARTHUR VAN HOFF: Thank you.
Thank you very much, Jarek.
My name is Arthur van Hoff.
I'm the CTO of Flipboard.
I'm sure a lot of you have
heard of Flipboard.
Flipboard is a social
magazine.
It's a magazine that is curated
by your friends, your
friends on Twitter, Facebook,
and actually since last week
on Google+, and YouTube.
And that's why we're here.
Flipboard helps you find and
discover interesting content.
Originally an iPad application,
it's designed for
a magazine format,
but we've also
created an iPhone version.
And since last week, we now also
have an Android version,
which we'll show you.
When you get the content, you
get it in a paginated format.
There's no scrolling
in Flipboard.
And one of the reasons for that
is it makes it a much
easier to read to find something
and quickly page
through a feed.
And if you like something, you
can tap on it, zoom in, and
explore more.
For some partners, we
have full content.
We have partnerships, so we can
share the whole article.
And for some content, you can
only see an excerpt, and we
send you to the original
website.
Flipboard has already supported
video since the launch.
We supported YouTube video
playback as early as two years
ago, but we're now allowing you
to log in to your YouTube
account and get all your
personal subscriptions and
also to interact with the video,
add comments, and see
the comments, and like
videos, et cetera.
That is what has been added.
So with that, I'm going to hand
it over to Jason, who did
a lot of the actual hard work of
implementing this before we
launch into a quick demo.
JASON CULVERHOUSE: So, we use
the pure YouTube data API, the
RESTful interfaces,
all of JSON.
We're using the search API for
users for video so you can
find people to follow.
All the standard feeds
trending on
the web, most popular.
We let you view individual
subscriptions or everything
that you've subscribe to is kind
of the default of what
you can flip through.
We're using all of the rating,
the commenting.
We allow you to subscribe.
And then after we have all this
information on Flipboard,
we can actually surface
interesting content from your
social graph that's
on YouTube.
It will show up in your
cover stories.
And then we can also aggregate
all of the stuff that people,
all the videos that they're
watching on Flipboard
themselves, and then it's what's
trending or popular on
Flipboard that's on YouTube.
And so we try to be smart
in the API usage.
So like I said, we
just use JSON.
The YouTube format, as you
saw, is very verbose.
We actually filter a lot of
stuff just to get what we
want, so we don't transfer too
much data to things that we
aren't using.
Sometimes, we put filters, like
this filter, would just
be things that were
mobile videos.
Actually, probably pretty
aggressive, if you were to do
that filter, someone will go
to their uploads and see an
old video and say why
isn't it here?
Because it may not be for the
mobile schema, but actually,
it'll still play on
their device.
We use a lot of the query
language, because we're trying
to get the new stuff in your
feed, the new subscription, so
we only grab what's required.
And you can do that with the
API, which is really nice.
And again, we also limit the
size of the JSON responses by
really digging in and
just grabbing the
pieces that are required.
So actually, there's a
new JSON seed format.
I don't know if everyone uses
the API, which is a lot
cleaner as far as a JSON format
versus the existing
JSON format, which is kind
of exploded XML.
But not every feed supports
it, so actually,
we don't use that.
Now, I'll go to Arthur
for a demo.
ARTHUR VAN HOFF: So
Flipboard is a
magazine, as I was saying.
And what you're seeing here
is the cover page.
It basically shows you
a selection of
stories from your Flipboard.
It also shows you on the right
all the contributors of those
stories that I go to
and Nexus 7 tablet
hands-on video posted.
And then I flip over to
my table of contents.
And in my table of contents I
immediately see the cover
story style at the top.
And the cover story style is
intended to be a selection of
the best content that is
selected especially for you.
And that's done by looking at
your interactions with your
friends and content
on other networks.
So for example, when you look
at who you +1 in Google+ or
who you like in Facebook
or what videos
you watch in YouTube.
And we take all that
information, and we use that
as an input for a ranking
algorithm that creates the
content you might like.
So we're going to tap on that.
It takes me to a magazine
full of content that was
selected for me.
Here's an interesting article.
I'm going to tap on
that in there.
I can read the article.
It's a six page article, and I
can find out about the Nexus
Q. And then when I keep going,
it goes on to the next
article, photos about it.
I can also go--
let me go back--
I can also go and get some
new content if I open the
content draw here.
You'll see featured content.
There's news sources.
There's businesses.
There's all sorts of different
content partnerships we have.
I want to show you one that
I like particularly.
It was the National
Geographic.
It's great, because it's got
really fantastic photographs.
So if I go into an article here,
then what you'll see as
I'm paging through you'll
occasionally
see a full page ad.
It's an ad that's delivered by
National Geographic, and it's
almost part of the experience.
It's like when you're reading
a magazine, you also
occasionally see an ad.
But it doesn't interrupt the
flow of reading so much.
And also what's very important,
you never see it
sort of half.
You never sort of scrolled half
of the page, which is
very important for people that
are into magazine layout.
Let me show you some
videos playing,
which is very important.
Let's go to trending videos.
This is the view you get when
you go to a YouTube feed.
This is the usual selection
of fun videos.
Let's play one here.
I have not watched this
one, but I'm sure
it's going to be great.
So the audio's coming
out of the iPad,
which you don't hear.
So this is great.
I can also pull up any comments
by tapping down here,
and I can immediately see
all the comments.
This is coming in through
the YouTube APIs.
And if I like this video, I
can just hit the thumbs up
button, and off we go.
And this is because I'm already
signed into my YouTube
account, so the interaction
is very, very simple.
It's also live, and let
me refresh here.
Get an update of the latest.
And what is this video here?
Oh, that's the video that
Jarek just made.
Let me see what that
turned out to be.
Play.
It's a wonderful video,
I'm sure.
Come on play.
I hit pause.
Sorry.
What a wonderful
effect, Jarek.
I'm impressed.
But as you can see, it's live.
And it really does work.
Last thing I want to show you is
so you can also do searches
by the way.
This is a search for the io12
tag, and it shows you posts on
Google+ from the conference,
which I really like.
I also want to really briefly
show you this working on this
wonderful device that
occasionally works.
You, there we go.
And that box is going
to go away.
That's perfect.
We did on your telephone.
If I tap on that, it takes me
to Flipboard, and I got the
same kind of layout, except
that the paging is now
vertical rather than horizontal
because it's a
portrait device.
So again, I got the same
video over here.
Click on to my cover stories.
I get to read my cover stories
and interact with them.
If I see video I like I can just
tap on it and immediately
get all the comments
and get feedback.
So there you have it.
Flipboard on Android, Flipboard
on iPad, Flipboard
integrated with YouTube.
It's awesome, and it's free.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thank
you, Arthur.
Great demos.
I think much better
than my demos.
All right, so now we talked
about creation and curation.
Let's talk about consumption.
So when it comes to the API,
there's a couple of different
ways in which you can integrate
YouTube video
playback on mobile devices.
The simplest one, on Android,
is just by drawing an intent
and launching the YouTube app.
One of our API partners referred
to this as the outer
body experience, which I find
actually very accurate.
It works well.
It's reliable and so
forth, and it's
actually quite simple.
As you see, you really don't
need to write a bunch of code.
And you can do the same
thing on iOS by using
the open URL method.
If you want to get a little more
sophisticated, you can
use the web view approach.
And some people love it.
Some people hate it.
It does work for
the most part.
So really the way it works is if
there is an iFrame embed on
the page, and you render that
page inside of a web view on
Android or UI web view on iOS.
It will actually use our HTML5
player, and it'll work.
And here's a code snippet
for Android.
I'm actually setting up a web
view and loading a URL.
That URL actually uses the
YouTube API, the JavaScript
API, and it works.
And I can do the same
thing on iOS.
Now, we actually have something
even better coming.
And I'm really actually very
glad to say that we will be
offering a preview of some new
developments in this area.
So it's still pretty early.
We're looking for feedback, but
we wanted to give you a
heads up that this
is coming at I/O.
So what we're building is
YouTube Android player, API,
which allows you to integrate
YouTube video playback
directly into your mobile
application without the web
view, without having to cross
the entire technology stack in
your app with full API support
in a lot of features.
And here's what it looks like,
so it's very simple.
You can basically extend our
activity and call load video
on it and off you go.
So it's quite straight
forward.
I would like to encourage you
to come to our session
tomorrow, new Android Player
Tools, and we'll talk about
that and give you some cool
demos in more detail.
So let's look at
some examples.
And with that I'd like to
introduce Kiran, who's the CEO
of 955 Dreams, and they build
beautiful consumption apps.
KIRAN BELLUBBI: So
hi, everyone.
Thanks, Jarek for inviting
me over here.
I'm really happy to be here.
This is my second Google
I/O, and I'm having
a great time today.
We started 955 Dreams, my
co-founder and I, TJ Zark and
I, with one mission, and that
was to create beautiful mobile
experiences.
We've done seven apps as a team
until now with five Apple
hall of fame apps.
All seven of them app of the
weeks, and last year's iPhone
app of the year runner up
to Instagram, which
is Band of the Day.
And I'll show that
to you today.
If you have an iOS device, an
iPhone, or an iPad, you should
check this app out.
It's called Band of the Day.
After the demos hopefully,
you'll be convinced to go and
download it.
It's free.
All our apps have used
YouTube in them.
And we believe that YouTube
actually helps us create more
compelling experiences
for our users.
For us, when we think about
building mobile apps, we think
experience first.
And APIs and all the other
technical jargon really is
just there to help.
And let me show you
a couple of--
can we switch to here.
So let me tell you what we mean
by experience first and
how that sort of relates
to YouTube.
This is Band of the Day
on the iPad, and let's
go to today's band.
Every day, we feature
one band.
The music is essentially
full play.
I don't know if you guys can
hear all that now, but anyway.
We have YouTube sort of
interspersed in the entire
experience for the app.
A lot of our users are sort of
reading the content, some of
them might enjoy sort of just
browsing the videos, or just
listening to the
music as audio.
And the experience is really
just fluid and works
beautifully on the iPad.
I can show you the iPhone
version as well.
This is all the videos
for this band.
And if you switch back to--
so we have a few ground rules
when we talk about using
YouTube in our app.
And the first one is that we
don't like to see loading
signs anywhere.
So when we use thumbnails or
when we are preloading any of
the content for our users you
will never see a loading sign
on Band of the Day, and just
small things like this make a
huge difference for our users,
makes it easier for them, and
the experience is just really
clean and simple to use.
So if you look at the YouTube
experience within our app, we
haven't added comments and
things like that yet.
But we plan to do
that very soon.
You can share the video
with your friend.
You can send it to a friend.
You can just start watching
the videos directly here.
There are more features
coming.
That's odd.
Let me show this to you on
the iPhone really quick.
So the same experience but
more for one-handed
navigation.
Extremely fluid again.
Go to today's band.
Listen to the music.
They are full play songs.
They aren't clips as you see
with many other apps.
Here you see more YouTube videos
sort of embedded inside
of the experience.
Everything is preloaded
for the users.
Thumbnails sort of the
one click play.
It just sort of works.
We've had any questions that
we've had, the YouTube
developers have been really
good at answering.
But mostly we focus on the
experience first, keeping it
simple, preloading stuff on
a mobile device and never
showing the loading sign.
We've had some success
with usage.
So a couple of interesting
stats from our app.
In terms of engagement, 35% of
our sessions watch at least
one full YouTube video.
This is sort of a really
interesting statistic for us.
We noticed a lot of primetime
usage of the product, a lot of
the usage of the product was
happening in primetime
television hours, which
is very interesting.
So further solidifying
our user of
YouTube within our product.
9% of the average session
length, which is currently 17
minutes is spent on
YouTube videos.
And this was fascinating
for us.
So yeah.
That's about it.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Thanks, Kiran.
All right, so let's get into
Q&A. And to get it started my
buddy JJ is going to lead a
panel discussion, so I'm going
off to the external speakers
to please come up and
[INAUDIBLE].
SHANNON "JJ" BEHRENS:
Are we ready?
Hey, great.
We're ready.
Jarek has to go give
another talk.
What room are you going to
be speaking in, Jarek?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: [INAUDIBLE].
SHANNON "JJ" BEHRENS: Video
mobile, video gaming.
And what room is that?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: [INAUDIBLE].
SHANNON "JJ" BEHRENS:
Number five.
That's going to be
pretty awesome.
We got some super secret
awesome stuff
coming up in that.
But before he leaves,
let's give
Jarek a round of applause.
OK, so we got a few minutes
left, and I want to ask you
guys a few questions.
First of all, can you guys tell
me what languages you're
using to talk to the
YouTube APIs.
Tell me if you're using a client
library, and tell me if
you're using XML or JSON.
KIRAN BELLUBBI: We're using
Ruby in the back end.
We don't use a client
library on iOS.
We sort of manage the data on
the back end using Ruby and
then deal with it ourselves.
KRISHNA MENON: No client
libraries.
We use the RESTful
APIs with JSON.
SHANNON "JJ" BEHRENS:
Which language?
KRISHNA MENON: Java.
SHANNON "JJ" BEHRENS: Java.
ARTHUR VAN HOFF: Same here.
Java, OS2, REST, JSON.
SHANNON "JJ" BEHRENS: Great.
So a lot of applications do a
mix of talking to the YouTube
API in real time in response to
users as well as a lot of
batch processing.
And I know that some of your
apps do a lot of background
processing, so can you tell me
of the breakdown of how much
your applications talk to the
YouTube API kind of in real
time versus batch processing.
JASON CULVERHOUSE: For
Flipboard, most of what you
saw Arthur doing, flipping,
that's all real time.
But we, also, if you sign in
with your YouTube account,
we're going to basically
crawl and look at your
subscriptions and stuff.
And that's how things
will bubble up
into your cover story.
So we actually do do a lot of
background processing too.
And we'll also look at all the
people you subscribe to.
And then if you have other
friends, what are they
subscribing to, so we can
do a little social graph
computations.
But a huge portion of it is
going to be real time.
KIRAN BELLUBBI: We don't do
anything real time on the app
right now with YouTube.
Although I think commenting and
stuff will require some
sort of real time API usage,
which we might do soon.
KRISHNA MENON: Yeah, nothing
real time right now.
Most of our integration
is on the publish.
So that's our batch
processing.
After the users says publish on
the back end, we'll publish
it to YouTube.
SHANNON "JJ" BEHRENS: Great.
OK, so I've got a squirrelly
question for you guys.
I want you to tell me about
the future of mobile,
specifically creation, curation,
and consumption.
And I want you to tell me what
the future's going to look
like two years from now, five to
seven to 10 years from now.
And then I want you to throw a
Hail Mary and tell me what
it's going to be like
50 years from now.
ARTHUR VAN HOFF: [INAUDIBLE]
first.
KRISHNA MENON: Well, I'll
address the creation, and I'll
try to be as realistic
as possible.
So the trends we're seeing are
obviously it's video's
ubiquitous.
It's on every platform.
Creation is now happening
on mobile devices.
Things that were not possible
on those platforms are now
possible today.
It's becoming more and
more mainstream.
I think in previous times, it
used to be that creation was
1% of the population, using
a lot more of it.
And I think that trend's
going to continue.
KIRAN BELLUBBI: On the
consumption side, I think as a
user, what I'd like to
see is more really
high quality content.
I mean if you look at what you
guys did with Coachella
streaming live this year, I
think we want more of that.
Not everybody can go at 35, 36
to Coachella, and Bonaroo, and
Lollapalooza, all of them
in the same year.
But I'd love to be a participant
in that experience
at least through YouTube
on video.
Hopefully, in the next 10 years,
maybe there will be
some user created demographic,
democratic way of high end
news that we can consume on
YouTube, really high quality.
Almost like 60 Minutes.
I don't know if that's
possible on YouTube.
But maybe.
ARTHUR VAN HOFF: So in the
short term, I think that
search would be interesting in
video, like how do you find
videos about something without
really knowing all the tags.
That will be an interesting
project, and I know that
Google is working on that.
In the longer term, I'm going
to predict that display
technology is going get so cheap
that pretty much every
surface is going to be covered
with displays.
So you just going to spray
them all the walls, and
obviously, they're going have
to be powered by YouTube.
So wallpaper powered
by YouTube.
That's my prediction.
SHANNON "JJ" BEHRENS: Great.
So we have a little bit under
three minutes left.
Is anybody interested in asking
a question, and if you
do ask a question, you could
come up here afterwards and we
have a few YouTube t-shirts.
AUDIENCE: Hey, guys, so I have
kind of a technical question
about the switch to OAuth2.
I don't know if any of you
encountered this, but with our
app, when we switched to OAuth2,
we ran into a problem
with YouTube, where Google will
happily authenticate a
user even if they're not
an YouTube account.
And we'll get this access
token back.
Then when we do an API, we'll
get the no link to account
response back, and it just
feels really clunky.
It kind of feels like something
we felt that Google
should handle on their end.
When we say we want YouTube
data, and it's not a YouTube
user, they should just
be like, no, it's
not a YouTube user.
Instead of pretending like the
authentication went fine.
SHANNON "JJ" BEHRENS: So
I could answer that.
If you look at our YouTube API
blog, we have a blog post
that's called something
like Google accounts.
And the idea was that we'd like
to open up YouTube as
much as possible to people who
don't have YouTube accounts.
And so it's up to you to follow
the advice in the blog
post to correctly handle
certain types of users.
And then for the users who
aren't YouTube users who are
trying to do something that
requires YouTube user
abilities, there are
ways basically
to help him to upgrade.
So the blog post will help
you out with that.
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
I'm familiar with that.
But I mean could there may be
an additional scope, like we
need a real YouTube user with
a YouTube user name?
And in that case, Google
handles it.
SHANNON "JJ" BEHRENS: Why don't
you come, and we could
talk more about that
at the sandbox?
And if any of you have questions
that don't get
addressed today, I will be at
the sandbox all day tomorrow.
So please don't make me
stand there by myself.
JASON CULVERHOUSE: I
can answer that.
So for Flipboard, we have
the same issue.
But we don't want to create
the user's account.
Actually, there's an API where
you can just add a name for
their channel.
But we sort of just pop up a
dialogue box and say you need
to go to YouTube.
But we let people browse
anonymously too.
SHANNON "JJ" BEHRENS: OK, I
think we can get one more in.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I just have
a general question.
I would love to get
your thoughts on
Socialcam and what it means.
And if it's something that's
lasting or flimsy?
SHANNON "JJ" BEHRENS:
Arthur, I have a
feeling you have an answer.
ARTHUR VAN HOFF: Oh, I'm a big
believer in the Google Glass
Project and Recording
Your Life.
The big issue is going
to be again search.
I mean if I can record 100 x as
much content how am I going
to filter that down to
the relevant parts.
So I think that's going
to be the big thing.
I'm not entirely sure what you
mean the Socialcam, but that's
what I think.
KIRAN BELLUBBI: Are you talking
about the app Socialcam?
I don't know.
A lot of people use YouTube
in their apps.
I mean so do we.
955 Dreams, all our apps have
had some form of YouTube
embedded in it.
And users enjoy using
apps that have been
curated really well.
I don't know, I guess, if you're
fishing for some sort
of like, I don't think there's
anything wrong that they're
doing, per se.
I mean it's another form of
curation mixed in with content
that already exists
in YouTube.
And they're just surfacing
some of those videos.
And I think if it's good for the
users in the end, it can't
really be that bad for them.
I don't know if that answers
your question.
SHANNON "JJ" BEHRENS: OK.
I'm going to have
to wrap it up.
Thank you, guys very
much for coming.
Come afterwards, and we
could talk afterwards.
The hashtag for today is IO12.
We'll be at the Sandbox
afterwards.
And can we get one more
round of applause
for all of our speakers.
Thank you.